okay hammer 74 good luck
let's bezerk Florida let's play the
hillbilly attack it's not fun opening
play f4 hmm I think I've gone wrong the
pawn should be on f3 okay I'll play g4
cuz why not Queen d4 play g5 your
opponent's trying to show who's boss I
want to play 92 target the Queen win the
pawn I'll fee and head of the Queen cuz
I was scared of the bishop ooh this is
looking very nice okay the King has to
move good play this move reinforce my
Knights
let's bring the knight in I'd use of
this in this ah let's ping oh wait a
minute this Knights slightly not
defended let's move back 94 is a move
yeah
okay I don't like this knife for the
chest Wow reading with a party or 45
thanks so much for the chests I just bow
ties GABA did because I didn't like
blacks nights but maybe that was a
slightly dubious decision um if you're
just joining I'm down the queen also
down a ton of time but I have hope
kind of I have an outpost to hope plus
outposts should be enough compensation
for a queen Jack opponent for God's
check okay let's play play this move
well the Kings just stuck in the center
its defend mate maybe see for coming
yeah see for it's double up but let's
not blunder anything maybe this move
first
oh there's Bishop check oh that's
painful ooh I'm feeling the pain but
when you feel pain you have to stay
strong just pretend that everything's
okay I still want meat let's take a
thing doll
okay still a little bit of hope just a
little bit
check seventh heaven oh wait I can keep
checking check check check
is this gonna be double check mates
double check mates part to double check
mate this is double check and mates
oh so nice double check me part two boat
s gambits
oh oh so nice
so nice I mean I was dead but I hope
that's what matters
okay you two people thanks for watching